I'm sorry guys, but the chicken flavour definitely wins.
No way.
The shrimp flavour is peak.
I don't know.
I think the beef is really tasty.
I still can't believe how much we actually have in common.
Right?
Plus, we're the dream team.
A yure, a yokai and a yosei.
ever since and how we all came together because we wanted to
form an idol group it has to be fate i just know it
do you guys really think we can stop this place from being
demolished it's gonna take a lot of work but if we stick to
the plan i know we can save it right phoebe mm-hmm from my
time as a solo idol i have learned that you can accomplish
anything with enough determination.
It'll lead into our paychecks for a while, but it's a small
price to pay to bring this place back.
Don't worry about it, Mint.
This once-thriving May Cafe in the heart of Akihabara will
live again.
Mm-hmm.
Then let's give it everything we got!
Yeah!
Sunday!
Tonight's the big night.
You guys ready?
Yep, yep.
I'm working on closing the cafe right now.
So nervous.
Excited nervous!
I'll be leaving work soon too.
I'm so excited!
Good.
Let's make sure to channel all of that into our show.
Yay!
Running there right now!
And in recent news, there have been growing concerns over
more missing persons in the Akihabara area.
Four more people have suddenly vanished without a trace.
Officials are advising individuals to remain indoors as much
as possible.
Especially during the evening.
I'm your blossoming fairy, Phoebe.
Don't lose your head.
I'm your yokai princess, Victoria Roman.
My, my boo!
I'm your hunting ghost maid, Maintant Phantom.
And together, we are...
Yudai!
Me?
Be a part of our story!
We are...
EXE!
We
are so cooked!